hey guys it's Jas and today I'm going be
going a little example of what I'm
looking for on gex
spot in combination with f profile to
make a trading decision so in this
example uh it's a little bit before
London close we've come up to this level
we've just had this kind of bizarre
straight up rally we slammed into major
positive at
78 and it's also
happens to be the edge or the top end of
the volume profile
right now here you kind of have two
choices right either you're looking for
some entry to join what looks like a
breakout right and then you're looking
to go up and on gex spot you know in
that case it would be okay we get over
78 we get over that peak of long
convexity
and then we have a clear Target which is
at 150 so we see this positioning and
you know that's where we're looking to
either trim or flatten or or what have
you right the other choice you have is
to fade it all right so you're fading
the edge of distribution you're saying
okay well this is Peak long convexity
now I'm expecting us to you know
return maybe bounce a little bit
return and then your you know Runners
maybe down to Major negative at
928 so that's kind of the path that I'm
in my head whenever I see some you know
position like this this is the path that
sort of emerges uh in my head right so
you have areas where you know there are
transitions between positive and
negative and these usually give you
either you know ideally you can you're
adding to your
your position right um but it can be
places where you trim you know say you
just fade major you go back to this
position at
38 and then you take your core off and
then you maybe try to ride your Runner
down to Major negative
right uh now in the context of
that um you know which which way do we
pick right do we pick the breakout or do
we pick the fade now usually I'm
thinking about
you know a number of things right so
it's
Tuesday it's not a Friday right you know
Fridays you can kind of get a little bit
more loose with things but it's just a
Tuesday it's pretty quiet there's no
data um you know we're waiting for Tech
earnings after the close you know if
you're looking at initial
balance it's just ranging action right
there's no one here it's just people
fading the edges you know going between
your hvns and just like Ping ponging
back and forth right okay so really the
odds are you know either you were lucky
and you snag this long and then you exit
here right and you decide just flatten
or you're looking to actively short this
right
now you know I think for both long and
shorts you have sort of the same pivot
in this example uh which is ibh which is
at
44 um now I think you know obviously
this is a bit of hindsight but if you
were looking for that Trend continuation
you just did not have a
good entry like you maybe try to go
along here and then it's doing this
wiggling thing right
um no and you don't have a good place to
set your stop or you're getting chopped
up right or you're trying to short and
usually
you know it's hard to short off um in
this case you know you might think that
okay well if major positive is Max
complexity for Longs then maybe I take
an active short against it right but
what I found is that generally you know
major positive or major negative they're
really best
for taking your core off when you're
heading towards the level right so if
you're long and you're coming into major
positive it's better to trim or if
you're short and you're hitting major
negative it's better to trim um that
just seems to be a lot more effective
than trying to actively fade against the
level now in this example right we have
ibh but we also have this guy here at
39 so there is actually someone who is
actively short here on gex
spot and this is where you know you can
generally look for some entry where it's
some sort of retrace right like whether
you're looking for an Impulse High um
some sort of quick pullback where you
can see buyers or shorts getting caught
um and then trying to enter off of that
right so in this case you know if your
turn is short maybe you wait for us to
get underneath 39 and then you wait for
the pullback you join this guy and then
you know your core positioning maybe you
just try to Traverse this distribution
this positive gex area to the 20K which
is [__]
tiny uh but then that also forms sort of
the upper end of this pullback as you
can leave the rest of your shorts down
to ideally 928 which then ends up being
the
LOD and yeah that's all I have to say
about that um thanks for watching I hope
to do a few more of these and you know
that was my first one so please bear
with me um be try to make more of these
and hopefully it provide some value to
you guys